my name is Aaron I'm from down in Orange
County California attending the show
with a few friends of mine wondering if
I get a shout-out for my friend Ken
who'll be at the show ken has been a
great friend of mine since college and
has been living down in Orange County
near me but soon will be moving up to
Northern California meaning we won't be
able to hang out nearly as often so it's
hoping you could spend a cent a special
shout-out his way instead of a device
from The Sound of Music
I was hoping Ralph could possibly sing
so long farewell from the sound of music
in the voice of Sean Connery that would
mean a whole lot to canned if Ralph
could pull this off it mean a whole lot
to Ralph if Ralph could pull this up
this is [ __ ] pretty tender man this
is like Brokeback Mountain why does
every male friendship have to put you in
mind of guys spitting on their hands
intense
that's the only reason guys whatever in
the movie what do you want me for I
remember that scene I can't quit you it
wasn't that intense but you know Sean
Connery saying goodbye to Ken okay so
wrong farewell it's the tender moment
here okay this is what a good job it is
man my job is in here and listen you
figure out how to [ __ ] sing this song
has someone else if you did it well done
wrong would you stop it was just
watching the impression from one side
this is what it looks like he's like oh
you guys stroke
suddenly it's pretty amazing what I'm
looking away okay so long farewell auf
wiedersehen good luck I'd like to say
that I don't give a [ __ ] oh that's not
gonna get any better than that
Oh Lord
[Applause]
[Music]
you